У найвисокогірнішому регіоні Карпат -
Марамуреші - сезон вуличних свят.
На вулицях співають, танцюють
і навіть розігрують цілі вистави.
Серед учасників та глядачів багато українців.
Ми такі щасливі бути тут,
щоби показати традиції нашої країни. Це круто,
це неперевершено!
Яскраві вуличні дійства покликані відганяти злих духів.
Хтось це робить за допомогою опудал,
хтось танцює,
а хтось одягає важелезні обладунки.
Попри те, що місцеве населення
останнім часом значно скоротилося,
давні традиції в Марамуреші оберігають.
А подивитися на них найчастіше приїздять
через закарпатське Солотвине.
Адже Марамуреш краще з'єднаний
з українським Закарпаттям, ніж із рештою Румунії.